the last time we did a one of my
favorite videos on my channel
which where we talked about helping
people and i think
some things have happened since that
talk which is only a month or two ago
that i think we can add to it so so this
will be like a part two of that yeah
sure let's do it so
we touched on this a little bit there
but i've learned since
since we spoke last how
how can how
what's the word it's just it's such a
but you you watch my videos and you go
oh my god i want to help this person
or commenter will say mark you didn't
help this person and they don't
understand how
incredibly difficult it is to get these
people to
accept help because even though they
might say i just need help
yeah and they're they're crying and
everything is like
you know seems like all they need is
to walk into rehab and everything will
be cool but what i've learned
is there are so many obstacles
that are in the way of all that because
what i've seen is the the ability to
make
a good choice a wise decision
is almost like impossible for these
people who were molested or
abused as children when you were when
you were
sexually abused or physically abused or
verbally abused when you were six years
old
it almost it seems to me like it it
crosses the wires in your brain so
what's good is now
useless you avoid it and what's bad
becomes
attractive and that's all you'll seek
and it seems
that that's all they'll respond to is
something that that is a bad decision
everyone would would say
it would be unanimous that oh no that's
a bad that's the wrong decision right
but that's what they go for
yeah well what i find fascinating is the
parallel between
when we talk about getting people off
the street or getting people out of what
we deem to be
a horrendous situation because it is
there's so much parallel between that
and those of us that aren't on the
street and are more privileged but keep
going for the same shitty guy that
treats us like [ __ ] or
keep say we stay at the same job that we
hate because we're afraid to go for
another job where we may not be
you know as comfortable we all have as
humans
a fear of a certain level of
success or or whatever it may be
succeeding in general not necessarily
monetary success but just succeeding in
general we all have a fear of it
it's just that these people have it
on a level that
is so deep and so painful that
they mistreat their bodies and they they
mistreat
each other and it just it's dark
and it's at the very very bottom um but
i think again we talk about the fact
that i want to
we all want to humanize what's happening
this happens to all of us at a level
it's just that this level looks
and is on paper worse obviously because
they're not as functional as members of
society
but we all have that instinct to run
and self-sabotage it's just some are
more socially acceptable
yeah i mean people maybe like you and me
and a lot of my
audience might have a little bit of that
self-sabotage going on
in their relationships and in your
career in your
personality and whatever and that's
maybe why that my channel's
kind of become somewhat popular is we
can all relate to these stories they're
extreme versions of our
right stories but this is what this is
what
our self-destructive tendencies on on
steroids looks like yeah
this is what it looks like when out of
the gate somebody's like you ain't [ __ ]
you're not worth it
they mistreat you they teach you when
you're still in your zero to eight years
of really absorbing everything around
you they teach you then
you're worthless of course you carry
that into the rest of your life
anybody would if you had different
resources perhaps
it would look different i do have
friends who have been through
molestation who aren't on the street
but this is how it ends up sometimes and
other times you're
functional and you pay your rent but you
still
have that same tendency when the doors
are closed and everything's
quiet yeah you and i speak on the phone
sometimes and uh we were having a
conversation about somebody i was trying
to help and i was very frustrated with
and
and i asked you at some point like are
these people even helpable
is it even possible to change them to
fix them
because at some point on my channel with
two i've interviewed almost 2 500 people
only uh norman and eric are the only two
people i can say that are really making
a serious effort doing the right thing
and hopefully they're going to make it
out but everybody else just can't
or won't or whatever word you want to
use and i asked you like
do people ever change and your answer
was interesting where you said
you tell me what you said you said that
we just incrementally will
change we won't yeah we won't so we look
at we when people
watch your channel or are
involved in what i do they sort of think
that if you throw these resources at a
person that overnight they're just going
to be this different person and if you
think about people who are
functioning members of society we don't
even work that way we don't wake up one
day and completely alter the way that we
live our lives and our surroundings the
same thing can be said about these
people
as humans we are just making incremental
efforts to be
better but change and fix don't they're
not applicable
in a broad term i mean sure there are
those people that hit rock bottom and
they go [ __ ] i need to do something
different
but for the most part we're all just
taking
baby steps toward what we deem to be the
right
way to live our lives and um for these
people
there are so many steps just to become
base level safe and functional that it's
like
we can't expect to throw something at
them and for them to just go oh well
great my life is fixed
but we have a tendency to assume
that that's the case and we do that in
all aspects
of uh humanity we tend to do that we
like to just throw something and go well
it's fixed what's your problem well
i think it's human nature i'm very
guilty of it where you just want to
oversimplify and be like
oh you just need to go to rehab and
you'll be fine well rehab would be part
of it
but then the ability to not
self-sabotage until you die
would be helpful and to be able to make
good decisions and to be able to
handle money and not just burn it as
soon as you have it in your hands
in order you know the ability to build
trust in order to
you know trust others the ability to do
so many things that you and i take for
granted
that these people are just totally
incapable of right yes
how will you ever teach them that they
need a new childhood as we talked before
right and that's where mental health
comes in and i think
now we're having those conversations
more than we had previously
but it's
that's such a large hurdle
and it's
the people who are living on the streets
are the last people that are going to
get
access to whatever this new focus on
mental health even brings about
because first it goes to those of us
that can pay for it and that still make
all of these corporations the money they
need to make and then
very last come the people that
that need it in a in a very dire way
in some cases um so yeah i can throw
money
at christina or whoever or i can say
let's go to rehab right now today i can
pick her up in my car
but self-sabotage is the nature of
trauma and so she's gonna go back to
what she knows because
we're not going to be able to there's no
it's it's 30 40 years of
of therapy to get somebody truly
you know in most cases anyway i can't
speak for everybody i'm not a
therapist but it's so it's so deep that
it's like we can't just expect for there
to just
throw tape on a [ __ ] on something
that's broken and go well why aren't you
why isn't it working now i don't get it
yeah there are so many people that
viewers would love to see follow-ups on
that i've interviewed
or that we've tried to help that i just
can't bring them in again because it's
just too humiliating
yeah if you knew the back story of what
what they actually did when they were
offered help on a silver platter
everything they would ever need rehab
education job training
uh therapy you name it everything
and they what they did with that which
is you know either
the help either turns into enabling or
it turns or they flake
very often they flake or they just get
angry at you because you're
you're representing something that they
just are incapable of doing
right incapable and they get angry
because you're you're trying to do
something that they just can't and
they present it just gets ugly and yes
and i can't do those videos because it's
just
these people are not just i can't just
humiliate them like that well a lot of
times if you have
been fervent in your efforts to try and
help them they don't even want to come
in because they don't want to face you
and and
say yeah no i turned down the help
because they know deep down in there
somewhere that
that is valuable help that we're
offering but
it is humiliating for them and
it like i said like i keep saying it
just it runs so deep but yeah there's a
level of humiliation and that's why i
talk about
the fact that we in this country
specifically because this is where i
live and this is the country i know most
about
we have to figure out how to have a
sense of community because if these
people
if people in general experienced more
kindness day to day
our efforts wouldn't be so futile
but it's because all day every day
they're
for the most part not experiencing
humanity and kindness
that us showing up out of nowhere just
seems [ __ ] crazy
it does and i get that like it's like
you know with anything else if you date
horrible people all the time and then a
nice person comes along nine times out
of ten you don't even want anything to
do with that person
no you're like what's wrong with you why
are you being so nice to me why are you
treating me so well it's the same
concept it's just different setting yeah
being human is tough man it's a
challenge and i think the only way out
of this is
to to truly start to care for each other
no matter what we look like no matter
what we have in our bank account
it is about a sense of community and a
sense of responsibility to each other
and right now
culturally in this country we don't have
that we can't wait to point the finger
and blame and separate and divide
and it's going to ruin us yeah no i see
all the hate
in some some certain videos like today i
posted a pimp video and it just got tons
of haters and
the sex offenders same thing so i turned
off those comments but
but all that hate accomplishes nothing
do you think he's going to say oh wow
people don't like what i'm doing i'm
going to stop
doing this he's not he it just makes him
feel more shame more guilt
and that makes him behave badly for
another
20 years right it's just it's just shame
and guilt and and
you know all the negativity he gets
doesn't change anything
the only way is to understand
forgive accept help
you know by learning and forgiving
yeah only ch only then is change
possible but i'm not saying we're going
to transform a pimp
who's hardcore you know beating and and
exploiting women
and he's going to he's going to become a
humanitarian i don't know yeah exactly
but but we can show kindness
what's that we can show we can exercise
kindness and understanding i'm not
saying we need to go shake his hand and
say thank you for exploiting women
but what we can do is is offer humanity
to the women that are under him and even
offer a level of humanity to him yeah
and maybe a little communication maybe
maybe explaining how
how humans should treat each other maybe
he'll grow a little bit
i'm not saying anyone's gonna be
transformed but no but it's worth a try
hating him and marginalizing him and
beating him over the head about what
he's chosen to do
definitely isn't doing anything no it
accomplishes it actually puts fertilizer
on on what he's already doing right
he'll he'll do it more well it's like me
i got uh i think i told you that after
the last video i got a
letter sent to my office um
to me is really amazing
um i got a letter sent to my office
about the content of what i was talking
about and it was
totally focused on race and i don't
think i even brought up i i'm
almost positive i didn't bring up race
in our interview because that wasn't
what i was referring to
but it was a letter that basically was
saying that um
white people are uh victims and how dare
i spread
liberal marxist rhetoric and whatever
else
kind of summing it up that's what it
said that letter
only makes me more motivated to continue
to do what we're doing now because
i the negativity that people think
if they shame you that you're gonna do
something different
no you have you have fired me up and now
i'm excited to
to go deeper into the things that matter
to me yeah shame
adds to whatever behavior you're you're
shaming right so in my case it's like
socially acceptable behavior because i'm
doing my best to spread the knowledge i
do have if you were if you were selling
drugs and somebody said you got to stop
doing that that's terrible you're you're
a evil [ __ ] you wouldn't stop doing it
you would you would do it
you would do it for another 15 years oh
we have tried being ugly to each other
and it's not working
so it's worth it to commit to trying
something else that's all that i'm
saying like
i don't have all the answers but being
nasty
is not working out very well so how
about we just
don't i love that keep it to yourself
because whatever you have inside that
makes you want to be that way to another
human being
says more about you and your trauma and
your experiences than it could ever say
about me and i'm sorry to whoever hurt
you in such a way that you feel the need
to go after
the people on the street or me or mark
or whatever but
i'm i'm understanding enough of the
human condition as
are you to know that that's just a
reflection of
them something something they went
through or something that's something
they're feeling yes and
if we can all really try to adapt that
principle of like whatever is going on
over here is strictly over here and
isn't a reflection of us perhaps we can
get to a place where
the hate and all of that just becomes
uncool to even bother doing because the
people you're
sending it to it bounces right off
and then there's more kindness and then
we take care of each other and then
perhaps there's a little bit less
struggle and pain in the world
perhaps wouldn't that be awesome that
would be great that's what we're all
trying to do here all right monica thank
you so much for another
informative talk you're always
interested thank you
thank you very much what time is julian
gonna be here